Well, I guess it was like this, this is the same original. Look, I
can draw anything like this. I ca
n't draw, no
, I can't write.  Wait a minute, that's what I'm
saying to someone who's sick. You're right, I forgot I was sick.
Hey,
wait a minute, Michishita. I
wrote that I was sick, but I can't remember right now. I'm sick. Oh
yeah, I'm sick. I'm having spasms.  I
thought I'd definitely call it if it was Kakeru Michishita.
Well, I wonder if it was here or not. I just wrote it
down in broken hiragana under the Yamadare edition and
forgot it, so I
quickly learned the knowledge I had acquired so easily.  Just try not to brag, then
write the kanji, and then forget it. I do
n't need any sprinkles. My grammar is
perfect, but the pronunciation is right. So I tried not to brag. I was
bad. Yeah, I still
make mistakes, but I can forgive them now.